Tradition is the root of modernity, and modernity is an evolved
tradition. We
need to interpret the
five modern elements of traditional culture
that modernity needs, give them a uniform diversity of modernity,
and establish the identity of local culture
.  I'm
Hyo-man Kim, the representative architect of Yiruji Chasm Architects located in the location
.
[Music]
Oh, as
time goes on,
I am
revolting against the boredom caused by globalization and the modern era, and I have
a challenging tendency to build something other than newer architecture.
[Music] The
client is the planner of the dream of loosing out,
and the architect is the
expert who makes that dream come true
[Music]
Whatever the landlord asked for, the requirement was
clearly
life in nature
[  Music]
The site of our mouse was what kind of mountain it was in the past
, so it
can be seen that the topography of the mountain
was preserved and the building was seated
as it was.
From
the inner courtyard to the roof, a
vertical garden is connected, and
the
small gardens penetrate the inside, so
that anywhere in this Breaming
House, in any room, or
even in a room high on the second floor
, the garden is always next to you.
So, as a result, the whole house is nature and
all the rooms are
in close contact
with
the garden bell.  The
three-dimensional curved surface that can be said so far
has been an important element that forms the backbone of my architecture, such as the line of flight and dynamism.
One can think of it as something
that creates a type in any of my style
adhesive
examples